kiffen bald für alle legal flotten
feierabendbier kann man ja mal einen
dampfenden sind als minderjähriger
leicht zu trinken als orte alkohol das
ist eine normale pflanze sollte man
anbauen dürfen wie karotten in seinem
garten
nur wie gefährlich ist es für
jugendliche
früher cannabis konsumiert wird und in
höheren dosen desto höher ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sich auch
ernsthafte erkrankungen entwickeln heute
geht es ums kicken denn die neue
regierung will den konsum von cannabis
zu genuss zwecken legalisieren so steht
es im koalitionsvertrag
aber was spricht eigentlich dafür und
was spricht dagegen wir sprechen mit
ärzten und ärzten mit wilhelm schäkel
der viele jahre schon cannabis
konsumiert und mit nico der schon mit 15
angefangen hat
fast vier millionen erwachsene kiffen
laut einer umfrage mindestens einmal im
jahr
einer davon ist landwirt wilhelm schäkel
der besitz von cannabis ist nach wie vor
illegal der konsum nicht schickel
konsumiert in geringen mengen sagt er
so eine leichte freude vielleicht auch
aber ebenso eine super entspannt das
bedürfnis so nach überdrehten denken
fällt halt weg und es ist eben eine
angenehme form der entspannung nicht nur
schickel interessiert das thema brennt
jahrelang wurde darüber diskutiert jetzt
soll es soweit sein auf seite 87 des
neuen koalitionsvertrag steht zitat wir
führen die kontrollierte abgabe von
cannabis an erwachsene zu genuss zwecken
in lizensierten geschäften ein dadurch
wird die qualität kontrolliert die
weitergabe verunreinigter substanzen
verhindert und der jugendschutz
gewährleistet
offen bleibt wann das gesetz in kraft
tritt
die grünen haben seit 2008 zehn den
entwurf eines cannabis kontroll gesetzes
in der schublade
auf dessen grundlage könnte die neue
regierung arbeiten
[Musik]
hubert wimber war vor seiner
pensionierung
polizeipräsident von münster ihm ist der
jugendschutz wichtig das was wir jetzt
aus dem koalitionsvertrag entnehmen
können ist dass die ampel koalition
beabsichtigt das betäubungsmittelgesetzt
dahingehend zu ändern dass auf der einen
seite der konsum von cannabis nicht mehr
strafrechtlich verfolgt wird gerade wenn
es um jugend und gesundheitsschutz
angeht wir brauchen einen regulierten
markt den wir jetzt nicht haben das
heißt also wir brauchen auf der
angebotsseite eine wertschöpfungskette
die im wesentlichen unter staatlicher
kontrolle
vom anbau bis zum vertrieb an die
endnutzer über lenz lizensierte kein
halbes leben oder ähnliches läuft
verkauft werden soll es dann nur an
erwachsene
aber was ist überhaupt drin im cannabis
antworten liefert professoren kirsten
müller weil in beiden wichtigsten
inhaltsstoffe sind das thc und das cbd
thc sicherlich die substanz im cannabis
die hauptsächlich für die wirkung
verantwortlich ist und die auch
hauptsächlich für die wirkung zuständig
ist die freizeit konsumenten wünschen
also eine beruhigende dämpfende
vielleicht auch ein wenig
euphorisierende wirkung für bds eine
substanz die noch gar nicht so lange im
fokus ist die man hat es so ein bisschen
vernachlässigt und bis heute weiß man
auch gar nicht ganz genau wie cbd
überhaupt im körper wirkt man weiß dass
es so einen gegenspieler zum thc ist
kritiker warnen dass durch eine
legalisierung häufiger psychosen
auftreten könnten das ist ein zustand in
dem betroffene die realität verändert
wahrnehmen halluzinationen oder waren
vorstellung entwickeln
wir haben keine hinweise dass werden
erwachsene in geringer oder moderator
menge cannabis einnehmen dass die
dadurch eine psychose erleiden können
was natürlich jeder mensch haben kann
ist wenn er eine sogenannte intoxikation
hat also wenn eine hohe dosis hat das
ist ähnlich wie bei anderen drogen auch
also beim alkohol dann hat man eine
intoxikation kann dann auch
entsprechende symptome zeigen das kann
auch mal mit psychotischen symptomen
einher geben aber das cloud dann nachdem
die intoxikation abgeflaut ist auch
immer wieder sofort ab für erwachsene
kann es wenn der thc-gehalt sehr hoch
ist eben stärkere psychotrope effekte
geben aber eben insgesamt ist es für
erwachsene nicht gefährlich
ob gefährlich oder nicht laut einer
umfrage wollen 51 prozent der befragten
das geltende cannabis verbot beibehalten
jüngere sind eher für eine legalisierung
jeder das haben will kommt denke ich
jetzt schon irgendeine art und weise
dran und ich denke dass man den spaß mag
vielleicht ein bisschen dadurch
verringert und vielleicht auch eher
leute diesen zu anderen drogen greifen
würden vielleicht lieber dazu wenn man
sich eine gewisse richtlinien hält bin
ich eigentlich dafür dass cannabis
legalisiert wird weil ich nicht
unbedingt findet dass cannabis eine
schlimmere droge alkohol zum beispiel
das gefühl ist vielleicht legal besser
war illegal man weiß nie was auf den
straßen dort zusammen gebraut wird es
wird ja so viel gemixt und weiß man ob
das immer alles richtig ist wenn es
nicht aus medizinischen gründen ist
finde ich dass es gar nicht verkauft
werden sollte an
normale bürger in anführungsstrichen
wenn jemand an sowas kann kommen möchte
kommt er auch so waren so was kann und
so kalter start nochmal besser
kontrollieren meiner meinung nach sollte
grundsätzlich legalisiert werden das ist
eine normale pflanze das sollte man
anbauen dürfen wie karotten in seinem
garten ich denke dass einstiegsdroge
sein kann und dann
herangeführt werden
[Musik]
wissenschaftlich belegt ist das
allerdings nicht die meisten experten
sind sich einig cannabis für erwachsene
nicht automatisch zur härteren drogen
bei jugendlichen ist das risiko aber
deutlich erhöht
das liegt laut einem urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts vor allem
daran dass dealer auf dem schwarzmarkt
neben cannabis häufig auch härtere
drogen im angebot hätten bei vielen
teenagern ist gras längst lebensrealität
dealer sind leicht zu finden die
qualität häufig schlecht
der verbotspolitik nehmen immer mehr
menschen cannabis ein auch jugendliche
und sogar kinder haben zugang zu
cannabis auf der straße weil der dealer
fragt ja nicht nach einem ausweis und
wir haben das zusätzliche risiko der
konsumierenden durch beimengungen auf
dem schwarzmarkt
im gegensatz zu erwachsenen gibt es bei
teenagern das risiko einer psychose
unter bestimmten voraussetzungen
[Musik]
psychosen auszulösen wenn eine bestimmte
wahrscheinlich genetisch
vermittelte empfindlichkeit bei den
individuellen vorliegt
das problem ist die jugendlichen wissen
selber nicht ob sie so eine
vulnerabilität so eine empfindlichkeit
mit sich herumtragen
dr jürgen seifert ist leiter der
fachklinik allen grund hier werden
menschen mit suchtproblemen behandelt er
sieht die konsequenzen von früh um
drogenkonsum täglich früher getrunken
wird desto schwerwiegender sind später
die erkrankungen je früher cannabis
konsumiert wird und in höheren dosen
desto höher ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sich auch ernsthafte erkrankungen
entwickeln deswegen gilt es gerade diese
wohlhabenden gruppen besonders zu
schützen
einer der zu früh angefangen hat zu
kiffen ist der 20 jährige nico er wohnt
aktuell in der suchtklinik hat einen
entzug hinter sich nicht nur von
cannabis los ging es im alter von
fünfzehn mit alkohol und gras später
kamen auch härtere drogen dazu das hat
bei ihm unter anderem zu schweren
depressionen geführt nach den ersten
joint ging es bei nico sehr schnell
ich wurde von meinen besten freund
damals heran geleitet er hat mir ein
glas halt so einer zigarette gegeben
hatte keine wirkung aber ich wollte hat
die wirkung kennenlernen
und dann ging es ziemlich schnell zwei
tage später als erste mal richtig
geraucht und dann nach zwei wochen war
es regelmäßig
erst 1 gramm am tag und dann hat es sich
auch schnell gesteigert
toleranzentwicklung halt im schlimmsten
fall waren es 10 bis 12 gramm am tag das
den drei monate lang ich bin ich so
richtig drin aber wie viel wie für
joints sind das oder wie viel
kommt drauf an wie deckt man die
kontrolle aber wenn wir jetzt mal von
einem halben gramm ausgehen sind das
halt 20 124 ich sage es mal so drogen
sind als minderjähriger leichter zu
kriegen als vater alkohol das ist in
deutschland echt hart also da ist auch
viel gefahrenstoffe bei die meisten die
dann eben auch keine rücksicht darauf
die sind froh wenn sie loswerden
ziel der legalisierung soll die
austrocknung des schwarzmarkt sein
präsent zu sehen im görlitzer park in
berlin
auf dem deutschen markt verschlechtert
sich die qualität des cannabis seit
jahren immer häufiger mission dealer
andere substanzen dazu um das gewicht zu
erhöhen und mehr gewinn zu machen
sicherlich einer der wichtigsten gründe
warum eine legalisierung von cannabis
erfolgen sollte denn wenn man cannabis
legalisiert und durch abgabestellen an
die verbraucher abgibt dann ist
gewährleistet dass in der kann habe ich
blute tatsächlich nur cannabis ist dass
das nicht mit anderen stoffen
verunreinigt sind ist die tatsächlich
gesundheitsschädlich sein können seit
wiesen probleme auf dem schwarzmarkt
nicht nur dass irgendwelche substanzen
beigemischt sind von stöckchen oder so
um das gewicht zu erschweren sondern
tatsächlich auch gesundheitsschädliche
dinge wie plastik oder haarspray um das
etwas frischer aussehen zu lassen und
das größte risiko für die verbraucher im
moment ist die beimischung von
sogenannten synthetischen cannabinoiden
die tatsächlich sehr gefährlich sind und
die auch gesundheitsschäden machen
können und wo auch schon todesfälle
berichtet worden es gibt aber keinen
bestätigten todesfall nur durch den
konsum von reinem cannabis
anders sieht es bei alkohol aus jedes
jahr sterben in deutschland an den
folgen ca 74.000 menschen
mit alkohol kammern flächen
desinfizieren damit kriegt man
eigentlich auch jede zelle im körper
kaputt und die schäden die wir hier ja
auch sehen vor ort die langzeitschäden
sind bei alkohol deutlich ausgeprägter
als bei kanal ist das ist für mich kein
vergleich trinke auch gerne alkohol aber
man im alter sollte man das glaube ich
reduzieren man merkt auch mehr den
dicken kopf am nächsten tag und alkohol
ist ein zellgift
und ich glaube ganz bestimmt bei auch
bei 70.000 tote durch alkohol in
deutschland jedes jahr dass wir den
alkoholkonsum deutlich reduzieren
sollten und ich persönlich auch
und rundum
entspannten feierabend hier kann man ja
mal einen dampfen
strafverfahren im zusammenhang mit
cannabis halten die staatsanwaltschaften
ordentlich auf trab 2020 gab es ca 200
20.000 delikte viele werden wegen
geringfügigkeit eingestellt
fakt ist auch der staat würde am
cannabis ordentlich mitverdienen allein
durch die einsparung der wegfallenden
strafverfolgung kommen für den staat
zirka 1,3 milliarden euro zusammen
unterm strich stehen einsparungen von
4,7 milliarden
wie eine legalisierung aussehen könnte
zeigt der blick nach kanada da ist
cannabis seit 2008 zehn für erwachsene
legal gekauft werden kann es an
staatlich lizensierten abgabestellen
hier bringt die legalisierung mehr
steuereinnahmen und gleichzeitig werden
jugendliche geschützt denn der konsum
bei jungen leuten ist nicht gestiegen
offen bleibt woher das cannabis für
deutschland kommen soll ersten
schätzungen zufolge bräuchte ist
jährlich circa 400 tonnen
einer der cannabis anbauen würde ist
wilhelm schäkel er wird seit fünf jahren
nutzern für das baugewerbe oder um
daraus zu machen
würde auch gerne sorgen anbauen die mehr
als 1 prozent thc haben vor allen dingen
aber wegen des thc es weil das
natürliche verhältnis begrenzt halt auch
den ertrag vom dwd und ich möchte gerne
sorten anbauen die mehr cbd habe nicht
einmal acht prozent vielleicht sogar
zwölf prozent idee und die haben dann
vielleicht 45 prozent oder bis zu sieben
prozent thc und aus meiner sicht sind
das gerade die sorten die in zukunft
auch für medizinische zwecke interessant
sind und jetzt so in meinem alter kurz
vor 60 will man auch nie mehr kippen wo
man drei stunden auf dem sofa nachher
liegt sondern er vielleicht eine
anregende sorte oder eben
unterschiedliche sorgen die tatsächlich
auch eine unterschiedliche wirkung haben
so dass man eben im high effekt auch
durchaus differenziert nicht einfach nur
um horten sondern eben er auch mildere
sorten sagen
nico ist seit 15 wochen klien in der
fachklinik erlengrund bastelt er eine
sucht autobahn die zeigt ihm den weg
seines konsums von der ersten
erfahrungen bis zum tod nico hat die
ausfahrt genommen raus aus der sollte
jetzt
[Musik]
mache ich das beste aus meinem leben
versuchen ausbildung anzufangen um den
führerschein zu finanzieren freundin zu
finden familie gründen eigenes leben
haben nicht mehr abhängig von morgen
rest ziel muss ist ja sein einer guten
drogenpolitik dass wir die auswirkungen
für das individuum und für die
gesellschaft verbessern
und das gelingt meines erachtens nicht
über gesetze und verbote und strafen und
das sehen wir ja in den ländern bei uns
und wenn wir mal in die vergangenheit
zurückgehen die prohibition in den usa
hat nicht dazu geführt dass die leute
aufgehört haben zu trinken sondern es
hat dazu geführt dass mehr erkrankung
aufgetreten sind weil gepanschter
alkohol unterwegs war und es hat dazu
geführt dass die mafia stark geworden
ist die illegalen strukturen gestärkt
wurden viele fragen bleiben offen denn
am ende gibt es aktuell nur diese vier
sätze im koalitionsvertrag die ampel
parteien müssen sich jetzt
zusammensetzen und einen finalen
gesetzesentwurf erarbeiten der dann
durch den bundesrat muss da könnte das
gesetz theoretisch auch noch scheitern
ob und wann die cannabis legalisierung
wirklich kommt wird die zukunft zeigen